the government's announced with just a
few hours notice that anyone in spain or
traveling to spain
will have to quarantine when they get
back for two weeks
is this the right decision well i can
understand why the government has made
this decision
and it's a reminder that we can't be
complacent about this virus it does seem
to be on the increase in
some countries across europe including
spain it's
certainly accelerating in certain
countries across the world and of course
one of the big blunders from boris
johnson was back in
march was not quarantining those coming
from spain and france and italy because
that's how the virus
was seeded so i understand why they've
made the decision
but of course the way in which this
decision has been made in the last 24
hours is
frankly shambolic there are
holidaymakers in spain
at the moment confused and distressed
there are people about to go on holiday
to spain and the islands like tenerife
who are confused
and they don't know whether their
employers will allow them to take two
weeks quarantine the government just say
oh
we hope that employers cooperate well
you know to be frank i hope that i'll
win the lottery on saturday doesn't mean
it's going to happen
we need clarity from government now as
to whether those who are asked to
quarantine whether they'll get financial
support if their
employers refuse it them and we need
clarity around
clarity for those holidaymakers who are
currently in spain who are probably
saved up all year for their family
holiday
who are confused and distressed and this
is probably the way in which
this decision has been communicated is
obviously causing anxiety
uh you make an important point there
particularly around employers we'll be
asking at the foreign secretary to
provide some clarity on that and other
matters
at the same time though isn't the whole
point of the government's response to
covert 19 that it has to be fast
it has to be nimble sometimes these
decisions need to be taken quickly
well we understand why decisions have to
be taken quickly you have to act with
speed when responding to a pandemic and
one of the
one of the big criticisms of the
government which
is broadly accepted now across the board
isn't it that the government were too
slow in their response to the pandemic
even though
the pandemic was the number one issue on
our risk register
we know they were too slow to put in the
supports and protections for care homes
even though many people were warning
that social care we're talking now
i know we're talking about um spain but
i mean the point is
generally throughout the crisis the
government's response has been
slow and we've always urged them to act
quickly so look i don't
i understand why they've made this
decision about spain
in the last 24 hours this virus is on
the increase in countries across the
world we've got some countries
uh even talking about going back into
national lockdowns
for example so it's a reminder that we
cannot be complacent about this virus
but the way in which this was
communicated i mean it broke on twitter
because a a sunday journalist a very
good sunday journalist got hold of the
story
and then the government had to scramble
to confirm it that is no way to treat
people
who are currently on holiday in spain
are about to go on holiday with their
families to spain is it
as you say um i think a lot of people
will be thinking twice about any foreign
summer holiday
they've got butch even grant chaps the
transport secretary caught in his own
lockdown
have you got a foreign holiday booked
you planning a staycation or do you feel
a bit sorry for mr shafts
well i mean you couldn't make it up that
grand chaps is over there
on holiday in spain when he's the
transport secretary i think that tells
you everything about
uh the sort of the governments approach
this but personally
i mean we're here in lockdown here in
leicester we're still in lockdown we
don't know when we're going to
leave lockdown in leicester and there
are actually many people here in
leicester
who had booked holidays and are not
allowed to go on holiday
and in some circumstances they're not
getting the compensation
for the fact that their holidays have
been cancelled so that when the
government makes decisions whether it's
putting a city like lester into lockdown
or telling holiday makers they've got to
quarantine for 14 days
they've got to back it up with financial
support for people
because this virus will spread when
people have got no choice
but to go to work because if it's a
decision between
putting food on their table or losing
their jobs and staying at home
people are going to be even going to put
food on their table to feed their
families and it's why we're not
really getting on top of this virus to
the extent that we need to
because we're still not giving people
the financial support whether it's
whether that's when that has to isolate
through the tracking trace
whether it's on these quarantine issues
or whether it's when an area like
leicester goes into a local lockdown we
need better support for people
so they can isolate and do the right
thing to keep themselves safe and keep
everyone else safe
looking ahead it does feel um as if many
people are worried about what is coming
down the tracks got an interview with
tony blair we're going to be
playing shortly where he's talking about
the risks of a second spiker in the
automotive winter months
and part of the government's plan to try
and get us all ready for that is to
lose weight to try and put it from a
diet on a diet if you like to try and
cut the rates of obesity because we know
of course that that is
shown to lead to worse outcomes with
clovid 19.
what do you want to see from the
government's obesity strategy published
tomorrow
well i mean the government are talking
about giving people dieting advice and
encouraging people to take up cycling
and even prescribing cycling
uh on the nhs so it's not clear how much
money they're putting into that that
project
dieting advice and encouraging people
with exercise is obviously a good thing
and
actually labour's manifesto last year
talks about encouraging people to take
up cycling and giving people support to
take up cycling
but tackling obesity is it has to be a
much
wider approach you've got to tackle the
circumstances in which people live the
environment
in which people live i mean there is a
correlation between poverty and
inequality
and obesity the poorest spend a greater
proportion of their income
on food but it's often low nutritional
food because that's
cheaper so we need to give people
support to buy healthier healthier food
but the government have cut the health
the healthy start food vouchers
and to be frank it shouldn't take a man
united footballer and labour and
peace to bring the government kicking
and screaming
to give families food vouchers
throughout the summer
but we're also going to take on what i
call the commercial determinants of ill
health
i mean why are we allowing junk food to
be advertised
on pre-watershed tv two years ago
torrey ministers came to the house of
commons when jeremy hunt was the health
secretary at the time they came to the
house of commons and said they were
going to stop this
and then they just kicked it into the
long grass with consultation after
consultation
we need decisive action so look dieting
advice is great
ex more exercise more more cycling yeah
that's a good thing
but we need action around uh accessing
nutritional food we need to ban junk
food advertising
we need to give families support we need
to give people health
healthy start vouchers not cut them and
also these high energy drinks that kids
can buy in shops
i mean why aren't we banning that kids
shouldn't be buying high energy drinks
in shops so i'm looking for decisive
radical action
from government not more backsliding
okay well we'll see if we get that
decisive action
uh tomorrow another thing that we
touched on in the interview with tony
blair that we'll hear in a few moments
is scottish independence he believes
that it is a real risk now
that scotland could try and leave the
united kingdom
in the future and he says that part of
the problem
is that the labour party went off to the
left and played around with nationalist
sentiment
instead of being clearly strongly in
favour of the union
in recent years would labour under
kierstarma
ever support the idea of holding another
independence referendum in scotland
look the labour party is a united
kingdom party
and we've always believed since our
founding days
that we are stronger together we we are
better together because the people here
in leicester have more in common with
the people of uh
uh of lovian if you like and we have to
fight together
for the same issue the question was
really specific we will never ever
support holding another independence
referendum
no no there will be obviously scottish
elections next year and we will be
campaigning
for a scottish labor government in the
scottish parliament
we are not a pro-independence party we
are a party that believes in the
strength of the union
between scotland and england and wales
and northern ireland because we know
you're not a
independent party no but would you no no
we don't know
no we don't no we don't our policy is
not to support an independent
referendum and we won't be campaigning
for an independence referendum we'll be
campaigning to keep the united kingdom
together
okay now jeremy corbyn has described the
labour party's decision this week to pay
substantial damages uh to seven
anti-semitism
whistleblowers as disappointing and a
political decision
not a legal one is he right and is this
helping
labour rebuild trust with the jewish
community
that i think kirsten has shown
exceptional leadership
in dealing with this poison of
anti-semitism which was allowed to go
unchallenged for too long in the labour
party
i entirely support the decision that
kirsten and the
general secretary of the labour party uh
made last week
there can be zero tolerance for
anti-semitism the labour party
and that yes that means changing our
procedures on strengthening our
procedures
but also means changing the culture in
our party where anti-semitism claims and
accusations were
too readily dismissed as smears or not
taken seriously
or opinions were allowed to go
unchallenged in our
in our online discourse uh sometimes
even
in our local constituency meetings this
can this
is changing and as kirsten said in the
house of commons
the labour party isn't a new leadership
in that respect now
i have great uh fondness for jamie
cartman i served in his shadow cabinet
as his shadow health secretary and i'm
very proud
to have served in the shuttle cabinet
for many years for many years now
but on this particular question and i
think kerstama
has done the correct thing last week and
we will continue to do
more to stamp out anti-semitism in our
party
and challenge it whenever we come across
it you see you talk there about the need
to change the culture
in the labour party but some might say
that you
and kistama help to enable that culture
by serving
in jeremy corbyn's shadow cabinet other
people in your party refuse to do so
should you have done that
no no no no because i believed that
we should always do all we can to
campaign and fight for a labour
government
to fight to turn around our national
health service where the waiting lists
are going through the roof to fight to
give our children
the very best start in life by investing
in schools and their education not by
cutting
their schools by fighting to make our
streets safer by recruiting more police
officers
for example and fighting to improve our
economy so it's a fairer economy
and people can get a decent wage packet
at the end of the month and we invest in
people by giving them skills
for the future i think that was the
right thing to do and i think you'll
find there were
many occasions when i kept came on your
program or another on other
uh programs and i spoke out against
anti-semitism i said we need to go
further and faster
in the labour party and kierstama is
absolutely right
to be saying that anti-semitism has no
place
in the labour party it is a poison and
we'll do
absolutely everything to move this to
shift this to push this out
of the labour party and challenge
anti-semitism not just in the labour
party but whenever we come across it
in society which is why for example i
was very pleased that our shadow culture
secretary yesterday
was very forthright on calling out
twitter because twitter has been
absolutely appalling in the last 24
hours
in refusing to take on the anti-semitic
vile poison that we've seen coming out
of that particular
grime artist i mean this is what we mean
when we say we take on anti-semitism we
stand against anti-semitism
in every circumstance whenever we come
across it and in every circumstance